like i envy you because in a lot of ways
you uh
i don't know if you were innately born a
leader i mean look you you you've got
flaws you you like i know that you can
be short tempered sometime you have
you're impatient like me we could what
what what you know and that's and you're
working on that jess is a great wife
because she also calls you out on it and
you're like oh
yeah she's very quite grounding yeah
yeah does she does she ever say
like tom cause like obviously i've seen
therapy i i know every actor i think
everybody does sheriff say tom maybe you
should see someone
yeah she has yes she has
and what did you do did you say so well
there's someone that
her and i both talk to not at the same
time and it's been very helpful and he
actually brought the bg's documentary
with a different point of he said it was
i should watch it it's interesting
because there's this thing in psychology
where you can never be creative if
you're being
um you can never be in the creative mode
when you're in the survival mode
and he referenced the bg's documentary
because
as they grew to fame in the uh disco era
and that went out of fashion very
quickly apparently
they rose to fame it went up then they
were in survival mode
and they apparently i haven't seen it
but apparently they sort of regrouped
and they realized they could write this
music um
in a different style and because of the
falsetto that they use
and it was a male-dominated disco era
and as they came out of that the
falsetto was actually more of a
what they wrote lended more toward
the female voice and they wrote a lot of
music for a lot of dionne warwick barbra
streisand yes
exactly but you just said something that
i think is incredibly valuable and i
haven't heard it on the podcast and
maybe
uh it's so simple but you said you can't
be creative when you're in survival mode
yeah i this is something that's been
resonating with me in the last few
months since i've heard it and it's been
explained to me
and especially you know listen you can't
talk to anybody for more than five
seconds without the cove
thing right and it's hard and it's
different and
we're gonna get through it but what it
does it puts you in survival mode
and what we have to strive for
is to remain in creative mode and you
and i you and i you know we talk
all all the time about like hey what can
we do how can we be creative and you're
very
self-motivating in that way of like what
can we do what can we create
because the flip side of that is despair
and
feeling sorry for yourself and or making
wrong decisions based on
maybe what is now but won't be in the
future so
i'm rambling a little bit no i like this
you can't be creative when you're trying
to survive
you